la parole est à notre collègue madame
dominique estrosi sassone pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur et
porte sur les conséquences des
dramatiques intempéries survenues dans
le département des alpes maritimes qui
ont fait 21 morts et de lourds dégâts je
tiens à exprimer toute ma tristesse et
ma compassion à l'égard des familles des
victimes
je tiens à exprimer également tout mon
soutien à l'égard des milliers de
sinistrés
je tiens à saluer la mobilisation
exceptionnelle des services de secours
qui a permis d'éviter que le drame ne
soit plus lourd monsieur le ministre le
président de la république et vous même
est revenue sur place constater le
désastre humain et matériel
l'état de catastrophe naturelle a été
annoncée par le président de la
république
mais les exemples passés de la faute sur
mer et de draguignan montre que les
procédures sont lentes et que seul
l'état à la main pour venir en aide aux
élus en publiant rapidement les arrêtés
interministériels et en mettant tout en
oeuvre pour que la mobilisation des
experts et des assurances au total
monsieur le ministre les communes des
alpes-maritimes
pourront-elles compter sur la parole de
l'état et sur sa réactivité à mobiliser
le fonds en aide aux collectivités
mais face à de tels drames aucune
question taboue doit être éludée quand
l'état mettra-t-il en oeuvre une vraie
politique de prévention des inondations
la facture du déluge qui s'est abattu
sur la côte d'azur pourrait atteindre
500 millions d'euros or le budget annuel
consacré à la prévention des crues ne
dépasse pas 300 millions d'euros quand
les pouvoirs publics arrêtent auront-ils
leur discours schizophrène qui consiste
à dire tout et son contraire dénoncer
les ravages de la bétonisation tout en
exigeant des communes qu'elles
construisent toujours plus au péril de
la vie les administrés
les élus locaux ne cessent de subir la
pression de construire de l'état
durcissement de la loi sru loi allure
avec la préemption de terrain sur taxe
foncière pour les terrains
constructibles mais non bâti il est
temps monsieur le ministre il faut que
l'autre un terme à l'application
uniforme de telles lois
tenir compte des spécificités d'un
territoire pour nous répondre la parole
et à monsieur bernard cazeneuve ministre
de l'intérieur pour deux minutes
la sénatrice vous posez la question de
l'engagement d'états suite au drame qui
s'est produit dans les alpes maritimes
ce week-end et qui a conduit le premier
ministre à se rendre sur place et vous
nous interroger sur le fait de savoir si
la mobilisation de l'état sera à la
hauteur du drame je vous apporter des
réponses extrêmement précise d'abord le
président de la république a indiqué que
l'état de catastrophe naturelle serait
évoquée en conseil des ministres dès
demain ce sera le cas la demande du
président de la république et du froid
et demi je ferai une communication et
l'arrêté sera publié dès jeudi
deuxièmement je réunis au sortir des
questions au gouvernement l'ensemble des
administrations qui concourent déblocage
des fonds qui viennent en soutien
notamment des collectivités locales
ainsi que le président de la fédération
française des sociétés d'assurance d'une
part pour regarder les conditions dans
lesquelles on peut attribuer des avances
aux personnes en deçà du délai de trois
mois qui généralement prévost et nous
allons mobiliser le fonds catastrophe
naturelle dès les prochaines semaines et
les prochains jours pour pouvoir
permettre aux collectivités locales de
procéder aux travaux en avance de phase
et remettre en état des équipements
publics du ressort de leur territoire
vous inquiété du fait de savoir si les
délais seront longs les délais ne seront
pas long parce que nous avons procédé ce
gouvernement une réforme du dispositif
d'accompagnement des collectivités
locales après catastrophes naturelles en
réduisant le temps des inspections en
simplifiant les procédures ouvrant droit
à indemnisation et en fusionnant les
fonds qui viennent en concours des
collectivités locales pour faciliter
l'indemnisation et j'ai d'ailleurs
réhausser le niveau d avance pour éviter
que les collectivités locales ne soient
confrontés aux problèmes auxquels elles
ont pu être confrontés vous évoquer les
problèmes d'urbanisme
j'ai pu me rendre avec le plan de la
république sur place je n'ai pas senti
que c'était les conséquences et
conséquences de la loi sru ou de la loi
allure qui avait conduit à
leur population à la sueur urbanisation
puisque les bâtiments atteint avait été
construit plutôt dans les années 70 et